we're here at your premiere this is very
much your premiere show what were the
challenges and of going back to sort of
doing it on your own after so many kind
of big-budget films the challenges
weren't that really difficult it was a
matter of getting the movie done the
limited amount of time with without that
not that much money but I started off
you know swingers we had a lot less than
this and and it was an old old set of
skills that I that I was happy to see
that I still had we hustled around we
went cross-country filming through
different cities we we filmed in real
kitchens and on locations and and thanks
to a very experienced cast and a very
experienced crew we were able to pull it
off without without so many difficulties
speaking of that cast it's an amazing
cast too and I hear from my research
you've actually done a movie Robert
Downey jr. and Scarlett Johansson before
yes I've worked with them before in the
past not a little movie called Iron Man
Iron Man 2 and you know we struck up a
great friendship and and when I sent
them the script they didn't hesitate
they they jumped aboard for for much
less money than they deserve so with a
mind then do you think there's a chance
Robert Downey jr. will come back for
Iron Man for is that it maybe make a
movie without him well I'm curious I'm
about to go visit the Avengers set see
what they're up to on Avengers 2 and I
think people would love to see Robert
Downey continue the Iron Man character
but you know he's done it quite a bit
now I've had a few movies off so it's a
lot easier for me to say that it should
be done but uh you know I hope he
continues doing it and as long as he
fits in that suit there's no reason he
shouldn't
you